hello in this short video I'm gonna walk
you through the translation features in
Microsoft Outlook so that you can send
and receive emails and messages in all
of the different languages that
Microsoft translator supports I've
already got Outlook open here so let's
get started I recently received an email
from a customer that is written in
Polish I can't read the message but
that's not a problem with the
translation features in Microsoft
Outlook to translate the message all I
need to do is double click on the
message to open it up in its own pop-up
window in the message tab select
translate and choose translate item a
message will appear asking if I want to
send the message to be translated by
Microsoft translator press send and it
will open up a tab in my internet
browser with a translation of the
message if I need to change the language
I can choose between all of the
languages supported by Microsoft
translator after I press the arrow the
message is instantly translated
Microsoft translator can also help me
respond in another language I'll just
click on reply to compose my response
and here is the text of the email that I
already wrote it just needs to be
translated into polish to translate my
message I simply select the text I want
to translate click on the review tab at
the top of the message window click on
translate and choose translate selected
text this opens up a window on the right
side of the screen where I can choose my
languages from all of the languages
supported by Microsoft translator in
this case I want to translate the text
from English to Polish now I can click
on insert to instantly translate the
message or click on copy to add the
translation to my clipboard to use
somewhere else my message is now
instantly translated and ready to send
you may have noticed earlier when I
clicked on the translate features of the
review tab that I was also given an
option for the mini translator the mini
translator allows you to get instant
translations of words as you hover over
them in the document to set the target
language for the mini translator select
translate from the review tab as before
and select choose translation language
just choose the language you want and
you're ready to go
the mini translator is also available in
PowerPoint OneNote and word I hope this
video has been helpful in explaining the
translation features in Outlook for more
videos about microsoft translator check
out our youtube channel at WWE kam s
slash translator youtube thank you very
much